[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we bring in ben roethlisberger the
quarterback of the steelers steelers
interested in odell beckham jr ben
i have no idea that is way way above my
face
okay when's the last time you weighed in
on picking up somebody a free agent or a
draft pick
um
i probably i probably weighed in to
coach t a lot through like a text on
something i don't but
you know it's not like it's hey get this
guy or else it's just hey what do you
think about this guy or maybe he'll
shoot me a text
um do i know anything about this guy but
but not not a whole lot really
all right whose idea was it to have fun
with coach tomlin on the usc rumor
what do you mean yeah
didn't you guys show up with gloves and
oh is that your fight on there
oh no i just was saying hey like
[Laughter]
um
yeah i was um
because i had actually um
texted like earlier in the week i think
when the news like kind of
like breaking news whatever you say when
carson put it out there my agent called
me said your carson said and i'm like no
and he told me and then um coach t just
happened to he had called me or i called
him i think he was at his um out of town
for some personal reasons and i said hey
i said it looks like you got some things
to to talk about he's like what are you
talking about and he had no idea and i
told him and he's like are you serious
like it's news i'm like i think you're
going to have to answer for it i think
he's just pressed the next day and
that's what all this stuff came out and
so
i was speaking to the media the day
after that and i was like i you know i
gotta i've been with coach t long enough
i gotta go so i was looking for like
stuff in juju's locker and i tried i had
he had a sweatshirt but it was a large
and i would look too ridiculous so
i put the gloves on and had them in my
in the hoodie and i tried to just like
you know tip the cab just some very
subtle things so
um just have some fun how did how did
that go over with uh coach tom
he you know what surprise he never said
anything so maybe he didn't see it um so
next time i was gonna i was thinking
about doing like some just like
literally any school that's got
availability i was gonna try and do it
and see what happens
well carson senate said it on my show
and i was saying i was saying hey you
know um
you know are you uh helping with uh the
you know getting us you know coaching
candidates there and he goes yeah you
know and you know we're looking at a
variety of guys and he goes uh maybe a
wild card would be mike tomlin and then
he could tell from my reaction he goes
oh you haven't heard that and i go no
and i don't think america has either
they had he had he was
you know i keep looking around the
league and it's a war of attrition and
we've added a 17th game they're going to
add an 18th game but you'll probably be
out of the league by then but i mean
does this make sense i know that there's
money attached and that's the bottom
line but man it
it's tough to stay healthy no matter how
long a season is
it is and i think my wife and i were
just talking about this last week like
literally every time you turn on the tv
whether it's the bottom line or breaking
news or whatever so and so gets hurt so
and so gets hurt i get it's football and
i'm not trying to say it's because of
the extra games or whatever it is or
lack of pre-seasons or training camps or
you know i don't know what guys are
bigger faster stronger but i mean guys
are just getting banged up left and
right and and maybe it's no different
than usual but in my mind it feels like
it is and
you're right i mean it's it's how can
you
get healthy at the right time you know
towards the stretch of the end and
enough to win games and um you know it's
it's golly we went through it with them
we had groins and hamstrings there for a
little stretch and
um you know luckily those aren't as
serious as some of the other ones that
are going around right now okay but it
used to be that we would talk about you
and it'd be well ben roethlisberger can
extend a play like you would take on a
defender or have two guys hanging off of
you
are you still capable of are you willing
to do that or have you changed your
strategy
well you know if it takes it to win did
you see me go for that two-point
conversion the other day
i know you're confused with you know
who's back here but uh man that was
whatever quite an athletic move there
that you had no i didn't say athletic i
said there was no athleticism there it
was more about heart
oh is that what it was oh okay that was
your heart on display okay all right
yeah
that was that took about 15 seconds to
run two and a half yards so
um you can still outrun brady though
right you can sell still run brady no he
gets weighed down by all those super
bowl rings though you know
[Laughter]
how do you explain brady
i don't know um you know obviously the
guy puts his body through
avocado ice cream and all these crazy
you know the craziness that he does and
um i know that he puts
the work in the time and effort like
through film study through work things
like that and
um
golly he's just
he's unbelievable i don't know how to
explain it i wish i knew he's five years
older than you
i know it's unbelievable
unbelievable what do you think you'll be
doing at 44. he'll stand in the pocket
it still blows my mind that he stands in
the pocket sometimes like completely
flat-footed looking around
like i feel like if i'm flat-footed for
like a half a second like someone's
about to kill me it's amazing i i it's
unbelievable what he does what will you
be doing at 44
um being a dad and a husband and
probably coaching
little league something
um
i don't know yet there's
that's a ways down the road i was what
how far down the road
uh well i'm gonna be 40 in in march so
it's like four and a half that's lots of
ways okay is that your way of trying to
ask me if i want to play until i'm what
because that's that's the most unique
way someone's asking me how long i want
to play
and how would you answer it
i promise you i won't be playing
football 44. okay
this just in breaking news ben
roethlisberger announces a retirement in
five years i can go with that
well i'll be playing football in the
backyard with my kids i'll be doing that
what do you do
better now than you did 10 years ago
um
man i don't know probably read defense
um you know back then it was just you
know use your athleticism make people
hang off you i think
you have to you have to grow in that in
that area i think um understanding
um my teammates and men and trying to be
a better leader i think there's ways um
and i've learned this through the many
years i've played there's there's ways
to motivate to talk to
um different guys and each guy's
different it's not like you just go talk
to linemen the same and receivers
literally if you if you learn and want
to be a great leader
of men or of a football team you have to
learn how to speak to each person and
what motivates each person i think of i
take pride in trying to know how to do
that how to pull a guy aside
um some guys you just give them a look
you know i so i i take pride in trying
in leading
football players and and men
i obviously read into a lot factoring in
how long you played but i'm watching the
the game against the browns last year in
the playoffs and it was emotional for
you you know you were crying on the
bench and i thought this is it you know
losing to the you know the team from
your hometown
and then you beat the browns last week
and then like there was true emotion in
beating the browns like help me
understand the significance of where you
were last year in that reaction to where
you are this year in that reaction
playing the same team
well you know you hate to lose in the
playoffs right we always say one team
only one team ends the the season the
way they want to and um
of course something's probably in the
season they just want to get done but um
you know it's uh
sitting there with with pounce
knowing that um it was probably it for
him
um and what that guy meant to me i think
that was as much of the emotion as
losing the game obviously i hate to lose
so you get emotional you hate to lose at
home against the browns all those things
divisional opponent but that guy sitting
next to me just means so much to me um
and so i knew it was going to be tough
to get him to come back for another one
so that was part of the emotion of last
year and then this year i think it's
it's going to a place that i've played
many times it's an afc north opponent
i've won many times up there i told the
guys after the game
the young guys especially um
don't ever take winning
up there against that team for granted
i've done it many times i i don't take
it for granted like that that win meant
as much to me as as any of them just
because of what you have to go through
to win at that place
um the fans are awesome like i i'll
never you know those those fans are
unbelievable and so to go there where
it's loud where it's a good team it's of
an opponent that's why i think i had
that emotion after the game because you
still take it for granted he's the
steelers quarterback ben roethlisberger
joining us he's got the game monday
night against the bears
uh with the aaron rodgers news how what
kind of safety protocol do you go
through every single day
i have my tracer on nfl tracer
okay so you know where i'm at who i'm
around you can't take that off
oh you well you can take it off like for
a shower maybe but you better have it on
you if you leave in your locker for a
second they're gonna bring it to you so
that's the that's the the one way i
don't want to get fined so i keep my
tracer on
but
you know you got guys who are probably
not vaccinated do they have a certain
protocol like they go one way when you
go in the building and you go another
way
uh i don't like i said i don't know um i
i think you're supposed to have your
mask on if you're not back so i don't
know who on our team is and isn't
um i know i am so i don't have to have
my mask on but
um you know it's you still have to live
your life last year was such a bubble
that we all lived in it was so crazy
um
we all sacrificed so much people are
still sacrificing obviously now and
doing the smart thing but i
um you know i'm still trying to live my
life uh to the best that you know the
best i can
i saw where you reached out to some
quarterbacks in the offseason i think
one of the mannings i don't know if it
was eli or payton uh i don't know if he
reached out to drew brees just sort of
kind of understanding of what this
moment means and
i was always told if you're thinking
about retiring then retire
uh
is that fair
um to a certain extent i think you're i
think that's a fair point um i think it
depends on where you are in your
retirement thinking or you know it's
just what you know um
are you sitting there saying man 50 50
do i come back do i
you know do i retire if you're at that
point then you're probably right if it's
entered your mind that okay this this
could be it or this is the last stretch
then then i think you could probably you
could probably still do it i think each
person's probably a little different too
you know
when did your kids realize what dad did
for a living
um
probably about
two years my oldest one probably about
two years ago he's gonna be nine so
probably about right about the six or
seven mark when kids at school started
to be like
oh your dad does this or um
you know going to games like
understanding people wearing your jersey
or people hollering at you when you're
driving in the car or you go to
go out somewhere and they're they're
hollering at you the kids are like i
remember the first time someone like
holler like big ben
my kid was like what how does that part
like who is that dad
don't holler
okay does your son wear your jersey or
does he like another quarterback
no he wears mine he likes other guys i
mean he's got like he's got a claypool
jersey he had james connor jersey juju
but he always but it never fails he
always goes back to dad on game day have
you brought out the super bowl
big guy like he left he wears his little
like the remember we all had the like
the starter uniform like the one with
the little like rub the small helmet
with the little bar
he's got like 90 on the side of his
helmet you know so he's like a big dj
guy too and he likes to hit his little
brother so he does
is he gonna be a
quarterback
um
he's very talented throwing the ball uh
he wants to play football we haven't let
him play not not let him but we just
haven't done it yet um he's a very good
golfer and so i think he might do golf
the younger one is going to probably be
pretty good he's a little wrecking ball
i have played golf with ben and uh i
think you were just starting out playing
when we've been a while we gotta do it
again when when when we played in tahoe
and i remember i i tell the story and i
i've said this to brees too because we
played with drew brees
and he's the most competitive like how
competitive was he that day
very crazy very crazy yes
he bogeys the 18th
and ben and i are finishing our hole
and and
brees he might have parted he didn't
bird he walked off the green
and
and and so you're supposed to shake
hands and all and and and uh brees walks
off and ben goes uh i guess i'll shake
your hand twice i'll represent both
quarterbacks
he was intense
you can be competitive and still
you know
he could still shake a hand after a
round of a call
i went oh and the next day i saw him on
the driving range and i thought oh man i
he i'm not gonna say anything he walks
over and goes hey dan i had so much fun
yesterday and i go you did he goes yeah
i said
oh okay well i did two
me too
it was like
what what do you think of brees's
retirement here
um from football yeah
okay i'll say did some new news happen
from
his hair his
oh is there something different there
okay all right i got it all right fight
on fire
fight on something like that
hey uh you make time every year to come
on thank you we appreciate it and uh you
know hopefully you play as long as you
want to play but uh thanks again
i appreciate it thanks for having me
let's get golfing some time again thank
you buddy we'll find a third
yeah another quarterback let's find
another quarterback not breeze uh thank
you ben that's uh ben roethlisberger the
steelers and the bears that'll be coming
up on monday